- First, let me introduce you
to the directors and the producer.
So to my left, Lisa
Molmot, oh, sorry, Molomot
has directed and edited
award-winning documentaries
about the American
Southwest in recent years,
including "The Cleaners" and "Soledad".
She has also focused on
stories about education.
Her award-winning film, "School's Out",
has been an integral part of the movement
for providing outdoor
education for young children,
and her short film, "Teaching in Arizona",
is an inside look at the
teaching crisis in the state.
A recent Fulbright Scholar,
she teaches courses at the
James E. Roger School of Law
at the University of Arizona,
where she has worked with
the Immigration Law Clinic
for the past four years
and has also taught
in the UA Human Rights
Practice Graduate Program.
Next to her is Jeff Bemiss,
who is a producer, co-director,
and cinematographer.
He is an award-winning writer/director
who has worked in shorts,
features, and documentaries.
Jeff's work has aired on
network television and PBS.
He is a graduate
of the University of Southern
California Film School
and the L.A. Sanford Meisner Academy.
Originally trained in scripted filmmaking,
Jeff's film, "The Book and The Rose",
was a semi-finalist for the Academy Award
for Best Short Film.
Jeff shot and directed the
award-winning short documentary,
"Coaching Colburn", about a young man
with Fragile X Syndrome, which premiered
at the prestigious Big Sky
Documentary Film Festival.
Jeff is a Connecticut Artist Fellow
and a Film Independent Fast Track Fellow.
He freelances for disability
and social activist clients
and teaches film at Trinity College
in Hartford, Connecticut.
And Jacob Bricca, who is producer/editor,
has edited over a dozen
feature documentaries,
including the 2016 Sundance
Special Jury prize winner,
"The Bad Kids", and the
international theatrical hit,
"Lost in LA", sorry, "Lost in La Mancha".
Fluent in Spanish, Jacob
also brings experience
editing multicultural stories
such as "Precious Knowledge",
about Arizona's epic battle
to ban ethnic studies in public schools;
and "Beyond the Border" (speaks Spanish),
about four sons from a Mexican family
struggling to overcome
class barriers in Kentucky.
Jacob has produced two
feature-length documentaries,
is an associate professor
at the University of Arizona
School of Theatre, Film and Television,
and is the author of the definitive volume
on documentary editing.
So thank you for being here.
And you know, I know the audience
might have some questions
about what they just saw on the screen,
so I kind of wanted to ask some questions
that were more about, you
know, behind-the-scenes
and the process, right,
of making a documentary.
So, you know, I'm particularly curious
about the various perspectives
that you manage together.
And throughout the documentary,
these perspectives map out the breakdown
in state and federal infrastructure,
and the varying roles
community members in Brooks
County take to fill in that gap.
So how did you go about
establishing these relationships
with different members of the community,
and how did these relationships
inform your research process,
or what ended up making it on the screen?
- Is this on?
Yeah, I'll say a few things
and then I can pass it to Jeff
and he can pass it to Jacob since, well,
we probably all have something
to say about this, but
Jeff and I began filming this
in 2015.
And I would say like the
first year of filming
was more research than anything else,
because it was about
going to Brooks County
and understanding what was happening
and forming relationships
with people there.
And
I think the fact that the film is told
in so many different, from so
many different perspectives,
one, we felt that that was necessary
to understand what was happening there,
but also, you know, we were
just trying to figure out
what was happening there and to, you know,
for a long time and
understand it ourselves.
So I think in some way,
that's reflected in the film,
that we have all of these
different perspectives,
but we actually couldn't stop filming.
I mean, we were so shocked
when we first got to Brooks County
and saw what was happening
there, and we were...
The film sort of began
as a different story,
a short film about something else.
And within hours of
being in Brooks County,
we were like, "Okay, the
course of our film has changed,
and we want to make a film
about what is happening here."
And just, it was a four-year journey
of documenting from all of
these different perspectives.
- Yeah, we kind of, I mean, we joked
that every time we went
to Brooks County to film,
the ending got further and further away
and we kept bringing more and
more footage back to Jacob.
And sometimes people ask
about the vigilante group
as one group that, "How did
you get involved with them?"
And you know, Kate and
Eddie were different.
They were kind of open,
because they were used
to talking to the media.
But the vigilante group would,
kind of wanted some press,
but Michael Vickers would
meet us out somewhere.
And it took us about,
really about three years
of nagging him and begging
to kind of go on one of these operations.
And so that was a process.
And I think each group had its own process
of building trust, but it was something
that we kind of had to start at zero with.
And it was just by going back
and going back and going back,
and they would see that we
were shooting a lot of footage
and that we were working really hard.
And I think that helped build the trust.
- And anyone said there's
nothing we wouldn't shoot.
So if that gives you, I mean,
we had a lot of footage.
And I think in some ways,
some of it was just for our own purposes
to get our heads around
what was happening.
Even though sometimes we knew,
"Okay, this is getting off-track,"
it still informed how we
understand what's happening
and talk about now, you know,
what's happening in Brooks County, so,
and all of Texas along the border.
So yeah, it was a long, long journey.
- And the footage would end up with me
and I would look at it.
And we sort of tried to start finding ways
to take these some, you know,
in a way it's a series of
vignettes of different people,
and to find a way to put
them together in a way
that you saw the experience of one
kind of refracted in the other, in a way.
So you just spend a little bit
of time with the individual
who is found, you know,
carrying a water jug,
and we learn a little bit about him.
But that may be, you know,
it fills in an experience of
what that might be like, right,
what that part of the
journey might be like
for somebody who, you know,
fortunately, is found.
And so, you know, we had,
by the time we came to
further in the editing,
we had two main stories
and a lot of these other little vignettes,
and we just kept working
until we could figure out
how to piece them all together.
And obviously, it's Homero's
story who kind of anchors it.
And his brother and
sister-in-law and family
kind of became partners
with us as we filmed,
and then also as we've taken the film out,
they've been with us to
many, many, many screenings
talking about it.
- So one of the fascinating
aspects about your documentary
is the context.
You know, as you mentioned, you
started this project in 2015
and it first screened in 2020.
I think that it's true in many
ways, not much has changed;
but I also think the opposite
is true, a lot has changed.
And you know, between Trump's
2015 promise to build the wall
and the drastic changes
to immigration processes
caused by the COVID-19
emergency, things did change.
So how did the context and
impact of the documentary change
between 2015 and 2020, as you
went through this process?
- Again, I'll start, and
just keep passing it.
So, after Donald Trump was elected,
I think the first thing we
noticed in Brooks County
was there was more law enforcement,
more border patrol in Falfurrias
and around the checkpoint.
And that has all remained.
So that was like the most
obvious thing that changed.
And I think, you know, it was interesting
'cause in the process of making the film,
you know, I mean five, four or five years
is a long time to make a documentary.
And I was like, "You know, we
gotta get this film out there
so it's still relevant."
Like, at a certain point,
like things become irrelevant.
But, and there's no way
we could have predicted
that the situation now,
given that 2022 was the
worst year on record
for migrant deaths along
the US-Mexico border.
It is was by the United Nations IOM,
International Organization on Migration,
they just came out very recently
stating that the US-Mexico border
is the deadliest border crossing,
land border crossing in the world,
and last year was the
worst year on record.
And I think starting in 2015,
I never would've thought things
would actually get worse.
And now with climate
change, and you know...
One of the reasons, one of the things
we don't state in the
film about the situation
is the reason why people
come in the hotter months,
late spring and summer and
early fall in South Texas,
is because all of these
ranches are private
and what's happening on
the ranches is hunting.
So migrants don't want to
come during hunting season,
which is the winter, which
would be much more sane.
But, so they come when they can
and it's during the hottest months.
And so every August, you know,
we predict there's gonna
be media saying, you know,
all about, talking about
all of these migrant deaths,
and you get a couple of articles
every August, late August,
and then it just goes away for a year.
And then in August again,
you see another "New York Times"
article, "Washington Post",
and then it goes away.
And we've watched this for now how many,
nine years, (scoffs)
basically the same thing.
And nothing has changed,
except that it's gotten worse
in terms of the number of
remains that are found each year.
- I don't really have
a lot to add to that,
except that the people that
we've sometimes partnered with
in the outreach and impact for this film,
like the Washington
office and Latin America
and other groups and NGOs,
they're not very happy with the
Biden administration either.
Because really, as Lisa said,
the net effect is the same.
Really, there's not much change.
You know, the Title 42 ended,
but there's a transit ban,
and these things haven't really,
nothing's really moved forward
in a positive direction significantly,
I think is fair to say.
- [Lisa] Well, the Missing Persons Act.
- Yeah, the one thing is, it's interesting
because with immigration, you
know, you see the headlines
and there's a lot of partisan sniping.
But then you look back
at what's been passed,
and it really challenges your notion
of traditional left and right politics,
this issue of immigration.
You know, Reagan gave amnesty,
and Bill Clinton, as you
know from the film now,
is really his administration
more responsible
for these deaths than any other.
And yet the only president
to ever sign a bill
that took any responsibility
on behalf of the federal
government for these deaths
was Donald Trump, which he did
with the Missing Persons and
Unidentified Remains Act,
which he signed at the end of December,
at the end of his term.
So.
But you know, really the problem,
the death rate continues to climb
and that's always been a constant, sadly.
- So before I turn it to the audience,
I have one last question.
So by this point, you've been
able to screen the documentary
and talk about it across different media,
across different audiences, PBS, podcasts,
academics, border patrol agents.
Has the documentary's reception
by any of your audiences surprised you?
- Do you want to talk
about the Texas tour?
- Yeah, we've done a lot of impact,
a lot of, many impact
screenings with the film.
But one that sticks out in my mind
is Jeff and I, during the
height of the pandemic,
decided it was a good idea
to do a tour of Texas with this film.
We did a bunch of mostly
outdoor screenings,
like we had a screen and a projector
and we went around Texas.
And one of those screenings
was in San Antonio.
And,
there were some conservative
people in the audience
who, well, I know that from
just the questions they were
asking prior to the screening.
And during the Q&A,
this woman stood up and said,
"You know, this film really
has made me think a lot
about some of my views on immigration,
and thank you so much for telling,
you know, bringing this
story to my attention
and this, you know, is gonna, you know,
give me something to chew on."
And you know,
we've been on conservative talk radio
with this, about this film.
We have made a couple of trips to DC;
we did a Senate hearing and
a Congressional hearing.
We've, you know, we went
to Cuba with the film.
We talked to people, young people
who are thinking about
immigrating to the US in Cuba.
And it's all memorable because this film,
it's just, it's so interesting
showing different audiences
the film and knowing that,
you know,
we're all human.
This is not about politics.
This is about human beings,
and everyone gets that.
And it doesn't matter
whether I agree with
their politics or not,
or grew up in the same
way that they did or not.
We're all kind of experiencing
this in the same way,
which is just shock and
anger and, you know,
people ask, "What can I do?"
So.
- Okay, thank you so much for that.
I'm now going to turn it to the audience.
We will have someone walking
around with a microphone,
so you know, you can just
go ahead and raise your hand
and a microphone will be passed to you.
- [Leslie] Hi, thank you very much
for this really powerful film.
It's hard to even like
ask a question, (laughs)
I'm still processing so much about it.
This is sort of out of left field,
but something I've been
thinking about a lot
in the context of my own work
with migrant people in
Mediterranean context.
And I'm wondering about
the first, the opening
scenes of the human remains
made me think about these conversations
that are opening up again
regarding indigenous remains
that are housed in universities.
And I was just thinking about
this sort of visual archive
of material that you have
and also,
you know, both in the film
and then in excess of that,
and how you might be thinking about that
in relationship to
questions about remains,
about repatriation, about,
I don't know, accessibility of material,
like materials for people in the future
who might be looking through
that sort of material as well.
If that's something that
you've thought about
or has come up at all for you.
- Leslie, you're giving me more work.
Sorry.
(people laugh lightly)
I don't know.
- I mean, I do think that
Kate Spradley's group,
Operation Identification,
I do think that they collect
materials as they go along.
I don't think we've ever
gotten that question.
It's an excellent question.
And I think that there,
I could envision a time
when OpID comes to us
and says, you know, "We're
starting a new project
and we're wondering if you
want to donate your footage,"
which of course, we'd be
happy to do, I'm sure.
But yeah, I hadn't
really thought about it.
- [Lisa] No.
- [Leslie] Thank you.
- It's a really moving film
and thank you for making it.
I had a question about the
water, the barrels of water
and where they were in
relationship to where people were,
where people went missing,
versus people who succeeded
in getting through.
When they took the, what it
was it 14, 15 barrels out,
they disappeared,
I was wondering if that was also
from the vigilante group, on their land.
'Cause it, I wasn't sure which,
you put the Mariposa Ranch
and I didn't know whose ranch that was.
So I'm just wondering about
where water didn't exist,
for instance, on that
one rancher who said,
"Well, I have the water
source" for his cattle.
Did the water barrels help
reduce the number of deaths in that area?
- So Eddie Canales, who is the, you know,
spearheads that project,
although as you can see, the other rancher
who you spend a tiny bit of time with,
who claims credit for the
being the (indistinct),
he also does this on the
ranch that he operates.
But Eddie Canales figures
that they are useful
because he does, you
know, replenish the water.
And some, you know, he will,
every so often they go out
and you know, check them.
And there are times when they've,
when the water's been taken
and they will then replace it.
So you guys can help me on this.
I think it is really hard for him
to be able to document
X number of lives saved,
'cause how do you prove a negative?
- [Questioner] Well-
- Yeah.
- [Questioner] What about
the reverse of that?
Where the bodies, where more
of the bodies have been found,
is that where there are no rain barrels
because a rancher won't allow it?
- The roots are, and you guys
should correct me on this,
but as you can see from that map
that shows up before
they're doing that search,
there are a lot of ranches,
some of them are absolutely enormous.
The Gage Ranch is one of them.
And then there are other ones
that are relatively small,
and it is kind of a patchwork of the ones
that are where Eddie is allowed,
where they say, "Sure,
come and do your work
and put your barrels",
than the ones that he
does not have permission.
And I don't know if, so it's
sort of like the patchwork
is a little too inconsistent
to be able to draw immediate conclusions
like the one that you're asking for.
But I think Eddie would probably
say he'll do it regardless
of whether, (chuckles) you know,
exactly what statistics
are shown or whatever.
And the fact that the water is being used
clearly on at least some occasions
is proof enough to him that that's true.
And it is true that,
you know, the inference
that Mike Vickers draws from this is,
"Look, they're on the major routes,
and therefore he must be in
cahoots with them." (snickers)
They are on some of the major routes.
So I think it's fair to say
that they are having an effect;
exactly what that is, is
kind of hard to determine.
- And Eddie does use
the death mapping data
to choose where to put the water stations,
if a rancher will agree.
So, and of course, there's
snake bite and heat stroke,
and sometimes when you reach
that level of dehydration,
you know, the water may
not help at that point.
So, or they may not find
the barrels, or so forth.
And so, it's very hard.
- And surprisingly in the winter,
I mean, there are fewer
migrants crossing, as Lisa said,
for that reason.
And we did do a whole shoot
with people who are out
there hunting, (laughs)
which didn't make it into the film.
But there are, some deaths are
from exposure in the winter.
You know, it's rainy and it
gets really cold out there.
- And can I say one more thing
before the next question?
Because I really don't want to leave here
without saying this.
But regarding your comment
about seeing the Mariposa Ranch sign,
I think that might be the only ranch sign
we put in the film.
And it just reminds me to say
that the Yale Docuproject,
which is a media law clinic,
took this project on pro bono
as an assignment in a course,
and they went through
the film scene by scene
and gave us legal advice,
or sort of gave us advice
about anything that seemed questionable
or could be potentially
problematic legally.
And one of the things after
this three-hour consultation,
very detailed consultation,
very scary consultation that we did,
was we took out the ranch names
for almost all the ranches.
I think we had a bunch
of other signs in there,
and we took them all out
except for the Mariposa,
because we felt that
was part of the story,
like that was necessary
because we kept going
back to that same ranch
and people were referring to the ranch.
So we left it in.
We did get permission also
on that ranch to film.
I think we felt more solid
on that particular ranch.
The other ranches, we got
permission from the managers,
but we learned that that's not enough.
It's actually the owner
that needs to give you,
so in case you're ever
thinking of doing this,
there's a bunch of documentary
students out there.
So I just wanted to like give
a shout-out to that clinic
because that was a real
education that, you know,
and it was all pro bono and just amazing.
- Yeah, we owe them a huge debt.
They were really wonderful.
And then the other part of
your question real quick
is those barrels that were taken,
they were outside the ranch gates,
so those were on a public road.
I mean, it was out in
the middle of nowhere,
but anybody could have just
driven up and grabbed those.
And Eddie has his suspicions,
which I will not repeat,
but we don't know where, but
it's not easy to take 'em.
I mean, they gotta take those,
they took the poles out
of the ground and I mean,
it would be very difficult
to take 15 of those,
one person.
- [Lisa] And hide them.
- [Nancy] There's a question in the back.
- [Questioner 2] Thanks,
thanks for the opportunity
to talk to you about this film.
I have two parts to my question.
They're kind of different.
So just in the interest of time,
I'll just put them both out there,
and then if you'd like to
respond to either one of them.
One of them is about the
making of documentary.
So my class at Wesleyan had
the opportunity yesterday
to hear from Jacob about
the making of documentary
and narrative and narrativity.
I wondered, you know,
on one level I wondered
if in the working on
this film, if it affected
or how it affected your
thinking about documentary
as a media, you know,
in terms of just any thoughts about that
in terms of the edits you're
making and then the choices.
The other question is
about the subject matter.
So I direct a Center for the
Study of Guns and Society
at Wesleyan.
And,
you know, I was really struck
by the scenes around hunting,
and I think this kind of way
that hunting and surveillance
are also getting closer together.
In fact, I think there was a
court case about five years ago
where a ranch had to shut down
because of a injunction
because they were using...
What they were doing was
encouraging kind of safari hunting,
hunting of animals on the ranch property
as a way to make money,
but people could hunt from
their computers in New Jersey.
And so the technology of
doing surveillance at night
for the purpose of hunting.
And when you said that in the winter,
the migrants aren't crossing
because of the fear of hunting,
just also those scenes of the animals.
I guess my question was
if, I mean a lot, you know,
given how few of the missing
people have been recovered,
and mostly when they are the
finding is of dehydration,
but listening to the, you know,
some of the armed vigilantes
and just tracking that
a little bit myself,
I was curious if you
or any of the people you talked with there
thought that there also
is lynching happening.
- Do one of you want to
take the first question
and then I'll...
I mean, the second question,
then I'll take the first?
- Well, there was a case of lynching,
but I can't remember the details.
Do you remember the details of that?
But I, yeah, I can't remember, but.
The vigilantes did run into some problems
before we were filming with
them, for detaining people,
which they're not legally allowed to do.
So there's some question
about whether there was the
camera effect with us around,
and maybe they cleaned up
their act a little bit.
I was a little surprised
who those people were.
I mean, I thought it would sort
of be any cowboy with a gun,
you know.
But they were NASA engineers,
they were retired judges, politicians.
And they would, people would come
and spend their vacations
sometimes doing this,
tracking migrants on these ranches.
There was this weird
sporting element to it and,
you know, they were ostensibly
trying to stop traffic
from coming through.
But if nothing happened that night,
they were so disappointed.
And that was just again, this sort of,
this distasteful sporting vibe
to the whole thing.
- And I mean, they were
also proud of the lives
that they said they had
saved, in some cases.
Because, you know, as you can see,
if at that point you do want
to be found by somebody,
presuming that they will end
up (chuckles) returning you
to shelter and water and such.
But yeah, it was definitely a weird vibe.
And your first question
was sort of about making,
putting together the documentary.
And you know, this is,
again, this film is sort of,
it's an amalgam experience.
We stayed pretty close to the,
within each of the two stories,
we were very faithful to, I mean,
of course you have to
take creative license
with precisely when you tell what,
but we were very faithful to
the facts as they occurred.
You know, so you are there the moment
when Juan Jr. was found, just
like it's shown, et cetera.
But then there are all
the other little vignettes
that play around in there.
And so for instance, the
vigilantes are out there at night,
they think they see
someone, the scene ends,
and then there's just
an interstitial moment
where you just see brush at night.
And then you're in the car
with the sheriff's deputy
who finds someone on the road.
And there was, we had
advice from someone like,
"Just put those scenes right together,"
they make the call and here's
the guy and he comes out,
even though there were different evenings.
And we had it that way for a little bit,
and then we decided, "Well,
that is pretty misleading,"
that it didn't occur that
way that night, right?
And that it doesn't necessarily make
that much difference in the story.
So that was the reason why that
shot is in the middle there,
which is just a shot of things at night,
and then we cut to a new scene.
And so it's kind of
ambiguous, or I don't know,
you can tell me how you interpreted it.
But we invite the interpretation of,
"Look, they were out looking for someone,
here's who they found,"
and yet we're not directly saying
that that is what happened.
But on an amalgam level, that
is what we're saying happens.
Because they are alleging
that these are terrorists
and they're coming to town
to overthrow the
government from the inside.
And our experience from being there,
our meaning their experience,
they're the ones who shot
over this amount of time,
was that it's much more,
if you had to put it into one story,
this, you know, Miguel who
was, with the wet socks,
that is a pretty typical event, right?
That is the kind of person
who is found out there.
So it's sort of choices like that.
And then other choices
where we were really,
we wanted to make you feel
like you had been out there.
So there are moments in which we,
that are scenes that are
relatively leisurely,
where you just sort of sit
and you listen to the sounds.
And that was really important to us,
to feel like you could feel
like it might've felt out there.
And they would come back
talking about the sounds
(laughs) of the brush.
And that's why we ended,
and we also, like for
instance, at the end,
we always assumed there'd
be an ending song.
We had money in the budget
to license something.
We tried out, I don't know
how many different songs,
and it never, nothing
ever felt appropriate.
And there's a lot of music in the film.
I hope it's relatively subtle and such.
But when we went to the
credits, it always felt wrong.
And so we were like,
"Why do we need music?"
It's much more appropriate
to just be out there in
the brush with those sounds
and just let them play.
It felt more respectful, it
felt more appropriate, you know.
It wasn't, you didn't get
like sort of an uplift moment, but.
- Well also it forces you, the viewer,
to continue thinking
about what you just saw
rather than have some kind
of music be in your head
and you've moved on.
I think that's usually with credit music,
it's sort of to kind of jolt
you out of the experience
of watching a film, and
we did not want that.
We want people to (throat clears)
reflect on what they just saw
and have all of the
emotions that one might have
after seeing something like this, so.
- And we hoped that there,
I mean, we feel like
there is hope in the film.
There's quite a bit of hope with the fact
that people are out there
caring as much as they do
and you know, spending
in, I don't know, there's,
we hope it's not as bleak
as some moments might make it feel.
But it also, you know, like to...
Yeah, I mean, it's a film
about death, so (laughs) yeah.
- So I have a question that
came from a viewer on Zoom
and this is a follow-up
to the audience question.
So they want to know who
was your intended audience,
and you know, did you hope to reach
or challenge conservative
audiences or points of view
with your documentary?
- I'll start, and.
Yeah, I mean, so we decided to get,
well, decided, we were very
lucky to get funding from PBS
toward the end of the process.
And that means, getting funding from PBS
means the film will broadcast on PBS,
not HBO, not, you know.
And one of the great things about PBS
is the audience is half
liberal, half conservative,
and that just felt like the
right thing for this film.
So in terms of target audience,
anyone that will watch,
anyone that will watch
and listen, you know.
I'll talk to anyone about
this film and you know, so.
Usually like I always
tell my students like,
"You need to have a
target audience." (laughs)
Like, and I don't know necessarily,
I mean, we're just as happy
to share about this film
with a church group as we are, you know,
we showed the film to
border patrol leaders.
They weren't necessarily our intended,
I wasn't thinking about
border patrol leaders
when we made this film,
but certainly like in
the back of our minds,
like of course, we want to show
it to border patrol leaders.
So I, you know, did we have
a target audience, Jeff?
- I mean, we did talk about
making a 360 degree portrait
of what was happening in Brooks County.
We wanted to treat the
audience like intelligent,
capable of making up their own minds
about what kind of policies
should administer the border.
But in order to do that, you
have to know what's going on,
you have to witness.
And so I think sometimes we were thinking
we just want people to see this.
And I think we also felt that,
if people could meet the
families of the missing,
they would feel differently
about the way we're
administering our borders.
Certainly, lawmakers
would feel differently
about the policies that they are enacting.
- [Nancy] You have a question back there?
- [Questioner 3] Yeah, I have a question.
It was an amazing film, you guys.
Thank you so much for bringing it here.
I'm from Arizona, so it's
very dear to my heart.
Y'all are my professors,
so, you know. (laughs)
Just seeing this, I've spent
a lot of time in Douglas,
and so I'm very familiar
with the border situation in Arizona.
And one of the things
that I really appreciated you guys doing
was bringing all aspects of
how people become missing,
whether that's death or
dehydration or the unknown.
And so I was just wondering
if you guys had any stories,
I know that you guys
probably had a lot of different stories
and you had to be very selective
of which ones you included in the film,
but were there any stories of people
who were missing and were found,
or you know, just in a different
state, anything like that?
And I just really wanted
to also point out,
Bricca, you already did,
that the ending was silent
and just the sounds of the nature.
I really appreciated that.
It was almost like a moment of respect
for the people who are
still missing or lost.
And so I just, before you mentioned it,
I wanted to bring up that it
was a very beautiful moment.
I really appreciated that.
Oh, so my question was if
you guys had any people that-
- Were found.
(group laughs)
Were found, yeah.
- I mean, there were a lot.
We shot a lot of footage,
so there were a lot of
stories, you're right.
- And there are, you know,
as the title card says,
there had been quite a few cases
in which Kate Spradley's
group have been successful.
- Yeah, they're up to 100.
So they passed 100, so.
- And you know, one sort
of interesting thing
is that actually the way that
this sort of process works
of recovery and the coordination
between agencies and such
is actually much, much, much
more functional in Arizona
than it is in Texas.
So their rate is much, much, much higher.
The kind of percentage of
if you were to go missing
in Arizona and die,
whether your identity would be found
and you know, your
remains would be reunited,
is just, it's just a different system.
Texas is highly decentralized.
A lot of these counties
don't have much of a budget
or much expertise, are not
actually following the law,
there's no coordination,
there's confusion about responsibility.
And as you hear in that story,
even sometimes the funeral
homes are kind of, you know,
"Sure, we'll take your money,
and then we'll just pocket the money."
And you know, so there's...
And Brooks County is now
one of the better places
in terms of the way it's run.
But that's partly because
of sort of, you know,
expose on previous practices, so.
- And so, in Arizona, we've
got a medical examiner,
I live in Tucson,
medical examiner and an NGO
called the Colibrí
Center for Human Rights,
and they are in the same building.
And they meet weekly and
they compare the remains,
the DNA from the remains,
and then the phone calls
from the families, you know,
DNA from the family members,
and they can put these two
things together and make matches.
And they do, and it's very successful.
And as Jacob mentioned, in
Texas, that doesn't exist.
It's the wild west in Texas.
There's no centralized system.
And one of the reasons why
we've been to DC with the film
was to get NGOs like,
you know, what's happening
at Texas State funding
to do what they're doing.
They're, you know,
they're not funded by
the federal government.
They're writing grants.
They're doing this work as part
of research at a university.
So that has been a goal,
one goal of this film
is to help them, support them,
in this centralized system for Texas.
- And in fact, there were
two more stories we filmed
that didn't make it into the film.
One of them, the... and
both were identifications
that were done by Operation
Identification, OpID.
And one of them, the family
decided in the middle
that they just weren't ready,
which is understandable.
This is not for everyone.
And the other story,
I think we just couldn't find
a place for it in the film.
It was just, it was a
really complicated film
with a lot of stories.
- [Lisa] And it was a complicated story.
- It was, it was compelling,
it was a very compelling story.
A sister had died, and
then her living sister,
who was also undocumented,
was kind of stuck
between what they kind of
call two borders, you know,
the interior checkpoint and
then the US-Mexico border.
It's an area that sometimes is referred to
as the golden cage.
And she actually could, it was really sad,
she actually could not go
to her sister's funeral
because it was held
north of the checkpoint
where, you know, she had
known people and had,
there was family and she was, couldn't,
she was afraid to cross the
checkpoint that had, you know,
resulted in her sister's
demise, of course.
So it was just too complicated
to put in the film.
- And in addition to that,
she was in a domestic violence situation,
where she couldn't leave this situation
because she was stuck
between these two borders
and didn't have family around.
And eventually, I believe,
the authorities let her go to Houston
because of this domestic violence.
But for years, she was
living in this situation.
We met her, we talked with
her, we filmed with her.
And so it's like not, you know,
like this issue of these
interior checkpoints,
they have so many consequences,
even beyond death.
They create these situations
where people can't get medical assistance,
people can't get out of
an abusive relationship,
people, you know, can't go to a funeral.
It's like, those are
just a few things, but.
- [Nancy] And there is
one question back here.
- Thank you so much for this film.
This was like very hard-hitting
and like beautiful to see.
I have two questions.
One, as you mentioned, like you went there
and you discovered for yourself as well.
So, like curious if you
could share a little bit
about how it evolved over time.
And as you mentioned, you
could take in some stories
but could not do the others.
And the second is how like you,
it's amazing how you build those relations
and that trust with people, right,
from the authorities
to the vigilante groups
to even more importantly, the families
who like went through
a lot of like turmoil
and it was not like a story for them.
So curious about how you
kind of dealt with that.
And also you must have like shot so much
like in the car and everywhere.
Like, was there something as a filmmaker
that you were thinking about managing?
Like how did you manage filming,
like going out to the field, the desert,
when they were like
identifying the missing people
or like even the different stories?
Like, I'm just curious about
how that process was for you.
- I'll say about working
with the families,
just one anecdote and
then they can talk about
what it was like filming.
Omar and Michelle, who
are the married couple,
and it's his brother and her
brother-in-law who is missing,
they found us.
So we had a website
before the film was done
called MissingInBrooksCounty.com.
And right around the point in which,
of course it had been two
years, all of this had happened,
and yet they were sort
of back to thinking,
"No, we don't want to give up."
Michelle googled "Missing
Brooks County Texas"
and she came up with our film.
And she just wrote us on
the little contact form
and we immediately put her
in touch with Eddie Canales.
But they were also about
to make a trip to Texas
and they said, "Would you be
interested in meeting with us?"
And they really were quite ready.
They were, very much
wanted their story told.
And that was how that came about.
It was a weird, that's not...
We weren't soliciting people or anything,
but that's how that story actually,
that's how our involvement
with them started.
- And for the documentary
filmmaking students out there,
I see you all,
I have to be honest.
When we got that email from Michelle,
I was like, "Not another family!"
Like, "We're already
filming with two families,
and you know, this film
is getting out of control.
We've got the vigilantes,
we've got the..." you know.
And, but, you know, deep inside,
you have to explore every possibility,
even though I was overwhelmed
by the directions that we were going,
all the different
directions we were going in.
And so,
we wrote back and said, you know,
"We're coming to Texas next
week, like, can we meet?"
And we did, and it was amazing,
because I think very, very
quickly, we met in Starbucks,
we knew very quickly that this
was gonna be a good match,
I think in part because
it had been two years,
it wasn't as raw as some
of the other families.
But also, you know, we were careful.
We were like, "Look, go back as a family,
talk to your parents, talk through this,
see if this feels like a
good thing for your family."
And like, I don't know,
within hours we heard back
that they were very much
wanting to participate
and then we just began
filming probably the next day.
But my instinct at first
was like, "Oh no," you know.
"It's like, this is so complicated,
like too many families, too many."
I mean we've...
But to answer your
question, first question,
like you know, we did, we
have footage of other crossers
that we, you know, met that
were, that had given up,
you know, and from Honduras
and you know, all over.
It just, we have a lot of footage
that we never put into the film.
And so, but you know,
just a word, you know,
just a lesson learned, you
know, for myself as well,
is that you need to
pursue all different leads
and see where they go,
as difficult as it seems.
'Cause it can be very overwhelming,
having hundreds of hours of
footage and knowing, you know,
I come from an editing background,
knowing that someone has to like,
sift through all this footage
and make sense of it all.
And so, at a certain point,
you have to discriminate.
Yeah, but it was just, it was Jacob,
so I was like, "Okay, let's do it."
(group laughs lightly)
- And I mean, there are some
types of documentary films
that you really can research
and prosecute in a way
that allows you to be pretty
targeted about, you know,
you can search out
experts to do interviews
and lead people through things in a way
where your research will lead
you to what you want to shoot
and it's kind of straightforward.
And then there is sort of
the cinéma vérité ideal,
which is you learn as you go, (chuckles)
and you shoot a lot of stuff,
and you kind of make sense of it
as you look at what
you've gathered, in a way.
It's a much more sort
of far-flung and organic
kind of searching that you're doing,
that you're living inside of.
And that was what more interesting
to all of us, even though
it's harder to know that you're
going in the right direction
or that you know exactly what you're doing
in any given moment.
It starts to become clearer as
you start to form conclusions
about what it is that you've shot.
And in retrospect, like,
okay, yeah, it's a mosaic.
There are vignettes, you know,
it sounds easy to talk about.
But as you're making it, it can be,
you are sort of struggling to figure out
how the meaning that you're finding in it
can be put together in a way
that will express that
kind of meaning, so.
- So I think we're reaching time.
I just want to say thank you
so much for this conversation,
and any last remarks,
or anything that you
want to leave us with?
- I'd like to thank everyone
who's responsible for bringing
us here, a lot, it's been-
- Theresa.
(group chuckles)
- Okay, thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
- Charlie Musser, from film studies.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you for those of you
who've joined us online right now,
we know there are those folks out there.
(soft music)